[Applaudissements]
pourquoi certains enfants réussissent
t-il si facilement à l'école alors que
d'autres doivent travailler si dur pour
y arriver
si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est pour
vous offrir un nouveau regard sur les
difficultés d'apprentissage vous
connaissez tous j'en suis sûr dans votre
entourage des enfants qu'on a étiqueté
comme enfants dyslexiques enfants
hyperactifs qui manquent de confiance en
eux qui sont qu' on manque de
concentration ou plein d'autres troubles
encore comme ceci
moi je suis enseignant depuis plus dé 15
et des enfants en souffrance à l'école
j'en ai vu beaucoup
et malgré ma motivation malgré mes
recherches
malgré les formations malgré mes
adaptations pédagogiques et bien je ne
faisais que compenser ses difficultés
sans véritablement leur donner des
solutions
et pour ses enfants le travail scolaire
c'est vraiment le parcours du combattant
tous les jours du répit ils n'en n'ont
pas et dans leurs yeux ce qui est très
difficile à voir c'est mais qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas chez moi
et dans leurs mots eh bien on entends je
suis nul je suis un bon à rien je suis
un idiot et des fois ça va même jusqu'à
je ne suis pas intelligent
alors confronté moi même en tant
qu'enseignante est en difficulté face à
ses enfants eh bien j'ai décidé
d'approfondir mes recherches de trouver
des formations et fallait que je trouve
une solution est plus j'avançais dans
ses recherches plus le mouvement dans
l'apprentissage devenait un sujet
récurrent alors tout a commencé avec
cette approche qu'on appelle le brain
gym ça signifie gymnastique du cerveau
ce qu'elle met en avant cette approche
c'est que le corps et le cerveau sont
liés le mouvement permettrait une
meilleure communication entre le corps
et les fonctions cognitives c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui est lié au cerveau alors en
tant qu'enseignante j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt intéressant comme théorie parce
que avec l'expérience que j'avais déjà
j'avais pu constater justement que quand
je commençais les journées d'école par
une séance de sport et bien mes élèves
ils étaient beaucoup plus concentrés
plus attentifs
juste prêt à prendre et leurs
performances on était meilleur alors
j'ai décidé de tenter l'expérience et de
mettre en application un petit peu cette
approche par un rituel le matin et
l'après-midi de gymnastique du cerveau
alors en quoi ça consiste
ben c'est d'effectuer des petits
mouvements simples ludiques mais très
efficaces tels que le mouvement croisé
qui est un mouvement qui va stimuler la
connexion entre l'hémisphère droit et
l'hémisphère gauche du cerveau
alors ces petits rituels les enfants
ayons vraiment adhéré d'une façon
enthousiasme d'un an plus surprenant
d'ailleurs que moi je m'attendais pas il
manquait pas de dire maîtresse maîtresse
tu as oublié le petit rituel aujourd'hui
et c'est surtout que très vite et bien
j'ai pu constater les effets bénéfiques
de cette petite expérience déjà par la
concentration des enfants par leur
motivation à apprendre et finalement par
leur capacité à croire en leurs
possibilités
à croire en leur potentiel
alors suite à cette expérience j'ai dit
il faut continuer on peut pas rester
juste sur un une petite expérience comme
celle là et j'ai continué mes recherches
et j'ai rencontré des vrais spécialistes
du mouvement dans l'apprentissage qui
m'ont orienté vers des formations sur le
pouvoir des réflexes archaïques et vous
allez comprendre que le mot pouvoir
n'est pas à négliger très vite j'ai
compris les difficultés que rencontrait
mes élèves alors en fait on sait
maintenant c'est plus à prouver que
l'apprentissage passe par le mouvement
quand un enfant se sert de son cerveau
pour bouger et bien en fait il va aller
stimuler les connexions neuronales dans
son cerveau quand un bébé naît c'est
grâce aux stimulations sensorielles qui
le reçoit et grâce aux mouvements qu'ils
effectuent qu'il va construire les
connexions neuronales au niveau de son
cerveau alors qu'est ce que c'est
vraiment un cas réflexes archaïques et
bien c'est une réponse involontaire un
stimuli qu'il soit visuel auditif ou
sensoriel les pédiatres les tests à la
naissance chez les bébés donc justement
on voit déjà qu'il ya un lien entre le
corps et le cerveau parce que si les
petits réflexes ne sont pas présents à
la naissance c'est qu'il y a fortement
un problème au niveau neurologique
alors comme réflexe que l'on connaît
très bien mais il ya le réflexe de
succion par exemple bébé qui tête ou le
réflexe d'agde rythmant qui est celui
quand on met le doigt dans la main d'un
bébé hop tout de suite il va refermer
sur notre main est alors on est tous
contents en tant que parent parce qu'on
se dit au regard dit tiens ma main il
tient ma main en fait je vous rassure
c'est juste un réflexe et puis au fur et
à mesure ces petits réflexes ils vont
s'intégrer pour laisser place à une
motricité qu'on appelle volontaire alors
vous allez me dire quel est le lien
entre le réflexe et la difficulté
d'apprentissage et bien c'est un petit
peu comme si on avait un caillou dans la
chaussure ou un grain de sable dans
l'oeil ça nous empêche pas de marché
mais c'est quand même gênant et quand on
l'enlève et bien on est beaucoup plus
disponible pour ce qui se passe autour
de nous on est moins gênés l'attention
et les moins porté sur le caillou dans
la chaussure est bien le réflexe qu'ont
intégré c'est la même chose ça va venir
parasiter notre cerveau ça va réduire
les capacités d'apprentissage de
l'enfant
alors j'aimerais justement vous parlez
là d'un exemple d'une jeune fille qui
m'a vraiment touché quand elle est venue
me voir qui s'appelle kiani et quand je
les ai rencontrés et bien elle avait 12
ans et elle commençait ses premières
années au collège
et elle est venue me voir parce que ben
sa difficulté c'est que ces notes
étaient en train de baisser parce
qu'elle était lente dans son travail aux
scolaires
alors en fait elle m'expliquait qui
annick sa difficulté elles dataient pas
de l'entrée au collège elle l'avait déjà
quand elle était à l'école primaire est
elle était souvent privés de récréation
ses camarades avaient tendance à à la
réprimander beaucoup parce que quand il
fallait les en sport ou en bibliothèque
et bien fallait toujours attendre qui
anime la maîtresse vivait une grande
frustration parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas
l'aider donc du coup elle s'énervait un
peu sur qui anime est tout simplement
par manque de moyens pour pouvoir
l'aider et cette burqa ni quand elle
rentrait chez elle à la maison et bien
c'est ses parents qui du coup la gronde
est parce que les leçons n'était pas
terminée elle était mal écrite donc il
ne pouvait pas non plus l'aider dans ses
apprentissages donc tout le monde vivait
une sorte de frustration de comment
aider cette jeune fille et même elle ne
comprenait pas elle comprenait ce
qu'elle devait faire mais elle ne savait
pas comment y arriver
et bien chez qui a ni justement il y
avait ce fameux réflexe d'agri plan qui
étaient encore très présents
alors comment on le teste ce réflexe
bien c'est tout simple on prend la main
de la personne alors allez-y vous pouvez
essayer et puis on va venir stimuler
cette zone là de la main le haut de la
paume et on va aller vérifier quelle est
la réaction donc on peut avoir une
réaction motrices petits mouvements des
doigts ou une réaction sensorielle
est-ce que c'est agréable ou désagréable
alors chez qui a ni et bien le réflexe
était très présent au niveau moteur
envoyait un léger mouvement de doigt par
contre au niveau sensoriel c'était
extrêmement désagréable il fallait qu
après cette stimulation qu'elles
viennent se frotter la main pendant
quelques minutes pour enlever cette
sensation alors quel est l impact de ce
réflexe sur sa lenteur dans son travail
et bien c'est qu'en fait qui a ni ne
pouvait pas tenir son crayon
correctement à chaque fois qu'elle
tenait son crayon ça venait re serait
rusty mulet pardon ce réflexe et du coup
elle devait modifier sa posture qui
engendrait du coup une mauvaise écriture
une lenteur dans sa vitesse d'écriture
et tout ce que ça impacte et derrière
donc un manque de fluidité une
indisponibilité au niveau du cerveau
pour se concentrer sur son apprentissage
et ainsi de suite
alors qui a ni elle a travaillé vraiment
vraiment vraiment très fort pour
réintégrer ce réflexe comme en en
faisant des exercices de jeu de balle de
jeu de coussins d exercice du type on
froisse la feuille très fort et on l'a
défroisse pour justement arriver à une
motricité volontaires d'ouverture et de
fermeture de la main parce que quand on
part du petit bébé qui ferment tout de
suite sa main c'est grâce justement à ce
réflexe mon intégré qu'il peut ensuite
tenir sa cuillère et tenir sa fourchette
ou décider de la lâcher c'est devenu
volontaires mme ashtiani c'était la même
chose
alors une fois qu'elle a pu réintégrer
ce réflexe eh bien on a pu modifier la
posture quand elle tenait son crayon et
en modifiant cette posture est bien du
coup ça de l'écriture est devenu plus
jolie elle a réussi à avoir un rythme de
travail plus rapide puisqu'elle n'était
plus gêné par cette posture est
finalement et bien son cerveau était
final très disponible pour je dois
recopier un texte du coup je peut
photographier le mot recopier le mot
sans être gênés par ce qu'ils venaient
la parasiter au niveau de la main
alors ben ce que ça engendre et c'est
que déjà au niveau des relations
sociales qui a ni ça a été beaucoup
mieux avec ses camarades puisqu'ils
n'étaient plus à presles elle est lente
elle est lente elle est lente donc ça se
passe mieux
les enseignants n'étaient plus non plus
sur son dos à lui dire qui a ni
dépêche-toi elle avait un rythme de
travail comme tous les autres enfants
et quand elle rentrait chez elle
et bien y avait beaucoup plus de
sérénité beaucoup plus de calme puisque
c'est le son était écrite au complet de
façon lisible donc ses parents pouvaient
l'aider de nouveau dans ses
apprentissages
mais le plus important
c'est que qui agnel a vraiment retrouvé
confiance en elle parce qu'elle a vu
qu'elle a pu modifier les choses et
qu'elle a pu finalement passer par
dessus ses difficultés donc ça c'est
vraiment le plus important
mais elle a surtout compris aussi que
quand on a une difficulté c'est tout
simplement qu'on n'a pas créé les
chemins au niveau du cerveau et qu'il
faut apprendre à son corps pour pouvoir
créer ces chemins
alors les recherches en neurosciences
nous ont vraiment vraiment apporter un
nouveau regard sur ces difficultés
d'apprentissage et sur le développement
du cerveau humain et sur le rôle des
réflexes archaïques comme facteur clé
dans le développement du potentiel
humain
alors on sait aujourd'hui que les
réflexes archaïques vont jouer un rôle
sur l'élaboration des connexions
neuronales sur la maturation des
différentes parties de notre cerveau
donc ça ça nous permet d'avoir une vraie
avancée sur les difficultés des enfants
et les possible d'intégrer ses réflexes
tout au long de notre vie alors c'est
pas une baguette magique mais par contre
ça nous permet de redonner la motivation
à laon enfin sa confiance en ses
capacités d'apprentissage est ce que ce
n'est pas déjà là un merveilleux message
d'espoir
[Applaudissements]